what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to conor
mcgregor
savage moments before i begin do not
forget
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel
i am trying to hit 20 000 subscribers
that is a big goal
for the channel on top of that do not
forget to
ring the notification notification bell
that way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos
okay
just so you guys know i like don't watch
sports so i have no idea what
the deal is with conor mcgregor i think
he's good at fighting
[Music]
this man the notorious conor mcgregor
may very well be joe not just fighting
the biggest star in the world today i'm
a fan of conor mcgregor i respect the
work that he's done the ring he's a
trash trucker he likes to create
headlines
i wish him all the best in everything
that he does conor mcgregor the baddest
man on the planet
connor take a look around you got a lot
of champions a lot of grizzled vets
who do you think would give you the
hardest fight out of anybody on stage
right here right here the hardest
hitting 145 pound the real hardest
hitting 145
right here this guy tko's people when i
knock people out they don't [ __ ] move
they're like who the [ __ ] is that guy
no damn who i am i don't know why
but the reason he doesn't come across
this tough is because he keeps smiling
like and nick's little bro you know what
i mean how can you not like him
he's he's like he's like a little cholo
gangster from the hood
but at the same time but at the same
time he coaches kids jujitsu on a sunday
morning
and goes on bike rides with the elderly
he makes gun signs with the right hand
and animal balloons with the left hand
i've spent a lot of time joe
everybody in the company backstage i'm
starting first off everybody
i've ridiculed everyone on the russia
i just want to say from the bottom of my
heart i'd like to take this chance to
apologize
to absolutely nobody
[Applause]
i'll take over from here nate you can
bounce
take take a coffee break mate and by
coffee break i mean bring me my coffee
then i'm gonna crack him with a jab and
he's gonna he's a bit rude
he's a bit rude i'm not gonna wobble i'm
gonna put him away early it's gonna be a
first round ko mark my words
so i said i'd knock him out in the first
round and i knocked him out in the first
round
you can call me mythic max because i
predict these things
they want you to give us a quick count
to 10 both of you gentlemen if you don't
mind just if you wouldn't mind count the
ten
they can only count the five
because they are not on my level not one
single individual in this company
is on my level it's been an honor
calling your fight sir
thank you very much you're welcome let's
make a bet here
let's if you [ __ ] have how much do
with that half a million you're making
better with a half a million i gave you
notice 48 thousand you went from
let me tell you you went from 48 000 to
half a million wow
thank me and be grateful afternoon mr
mcgregor damn
what's your response to malonizi is he
on the radar is that a possibility
who the [ __ ] is that guy
that's what he always says he just acts
like he doesn't know you right now yeah
[ __ ] floyd cause i own the west coast
see stiffness when i look at that 155
pound division
slow stiff i feel like they're stuck in
the mud almost
the federal weights they hit like
flyweights so it's nice down there just
destroying them and
killing that whole division but i have
my eye on that 155 division and i see
them all stuck in the mood in there
so we'll see over time but guess what
have i been wrong yet have i been wrong
yet no
isn't this the guy that got his ass
kicked from mayweather 2015 was my year
i don't watch sports but that was
awesome 2016
is also my year every year is my [ __ ]
year
not the year you lost it i think
how does it feel to be a millionaire now
it's nice right
it's nice right let's be honest come on
it's nice right
it feels good okay i'll take it more
you're a millionaire
but one night connor do you know what
wrestling here
i get i hear my balls on your forehead
i i'll be saying about the talk and i
talk and i talk and i talk but guess
[ __ ] what
i back it up i back it up
damn no chance that's what you got
i changed your formula if you find me
it's a seller
when you're trying to fight me it's a
celebration you ring back home you ring
your wife
baby we've done it we're rich baby conor
mcgregor haters rich
break out the red panties we're rich
four at least you should stand up
because we can barely see you on the
screen
[Applause]
not polite he is not looking at the kid
[Applause]
dana 60 g's baby
ah you see fear of my eyes you see
nothing in my eyes
uh my my father raised me like this uh
like a man
i am his daddy [ __ ] slap that
[ __ ]
what these custom-made suits aren't
cheap this solid gold pocket watch
three people died making this watch you
know what i mean damn genius damn rumors
look at him
zoom in on that piece of [ __ ] proper
microphone that's a piece of [ __ ]
that's also a piece of [ __ ] wow
what is he doing why does he just keep
taking people's like belt thingies i
don't even know what those do
but i don't think you're supposed to
just take them sorry i'm late i just
don't give a
[ __ ] me and jesus are cool
i'm killed with all the gods gods
recognized gods
[Applause]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you damn
that's all right hey hey do connor
connor don't throw those [ __ ]
connor connor wow he kind of looks like
don't mess with that guy yeah take a
good look at him
surprise surprise [ __ ] the king
is back
the featherweights must beg now they
must
they must beg for pardon beg for
forgiveness
if that's the case if they apologize and
beg i'll leave the division
i won't terrorize them anymore they can
have their division back
they can they can go back to being on
the prelims i'm worried about you
i honestly i'm worried i love you
i love you like my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] pimp
rocky mick why do guys
when they're like fighting and stuff
threaten to like
do sexual things to each
don't care what country will see what
kingdom you are in
i'll find you and make you kiss my feet
uh this question is for eddie alvarez
i've been mentioning that conor mcgregor
is not a championship fighter
uh he only has two to three rounds yet
in your professional career you've only
went to the fifth round twice and lost
one of them what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
the [ __ ] are you talking about that's
the chance i love it
[Applause]
floyd's in the bahamas he's not even he
doesn't care about connor i was like
well i don't give a [ __ ] about floyd
either
unbelievable mystic mac strikes again
it's the [ __ ] dlwg [ __ ] the
diaz brothers yeah
[ __ ] those cockroaches floyd and i quote
wow his ass now what do you say that
[Applause]
i'm pretty sure he lost full floyd's
manager
[Applause]
tell him to come say it to me face
we need your assistance
and if you're down with team diaz then
[ __ ] youtube
yeah and he's still uncomfortable
[Applause]
[Music]
you can play with those fake belts all
you want the real jose
was ko eddie was ko'd you're looking at
the two-way world champion and that's
it you're the [ __ ] guy i'm the boxing
guy why don't you take over
trust me on that doesn't it now no one
in this boxing game knows what's coming
trust me on that when i
[Music]
the whole world is going
this guy seems very sassy but
i still can't get the idea of him being
like a little
a little angry leprechaun out of my head
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or disagree
do not forget to subscribe i'm trying to
get to 20 000 subscribers you guys
already know that is a huge goal for the
channel and don't forget to ring the
notification
bell comment below what you guys want me
to react to
next time